i think the question of failure has to
do with what our goals are hi there
steve kaufman here today i want to talk
about why people fail at language
learning now if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
so
what do i mean by that
what do i mean when i say that people
fail at language learning
well
if i look at the example in canada which
is the situation i know the best just
about every english-speaking canadian
has french at school depending on the
province it might be six years eight
years ten years of french
very few of those kids
graduate from high school able to speak
french very few
i gather from what i hear in other
countries english-speaking countries
that the same is true now there are
always some who end up speaking very
well and you know go off to the country
where the language is spoken but they
are
a very small minority the vast majority
fail
now i don't know what the situation is
in other countries
but i lived in japan everyone has
english at school the vast majority
don't understand english
uh
i travel in spain it's the same
now there's always a small number of
people who speak
english or other language as well but
the majority of people don't
i suspect that the vast majority of
people who study languages in fact don't
end up speaking the language
so
are they failures
again it all depends on how you define
failure
so
if i get back to the example of
english-speaking kids in canada
most of those kids passed their french
at school they didn't fail
they got
seven out of ten eight out of ten nine
out of ten whatever most of them passed
they had to pass to get out of high
school
so they didn't fail in that sense but
they failed in the sense that they
didn't learn to speak the language
um
right now i've been at my arabic
for three years and my persian for two
i can't say that i speak either language
particularly well
i really struggle now
my farsi is now better i've had an
opportunity to use it a bit here and
there around
uh vancouver north vancouver especially
west vancouver
arabic uh i'm now exploring you know
egyptian arabic with muhammad my tutor
and i do struggle in our conversations
there's no question but am i failing in
the language so here again
i'm not i don't think i'm failing
because i'm enjoying what i'm doing
i understand more and more
so i think the question of failure has
to do with what our goals are
goals that we set for ourselves or goals
that other people set for us
now i suspect that in our english
language school system in canada most of
those students have only one goal and
that's to pass the test they're not
particularly interested in speaking
french
so
they
succeeded based on their goal they
didn't succeed based on a goal that
sort of someone else expects of them and
that is the ability to speak
maybe in our school system
we should put the emphasis on
comprehension and not on speaking
speaking implies speaking correctly
so once you
attempt to speak or to write you produce
the language
so that the teacher can correct you
give you marks or even when you're
listening the teacher is going to test
you on your listening comprehension
setting you up for failure setting you
up for
you know things that you can't do
if we simply said
we're going to expose kids in school to
a lot of content
uh hopefully content they're interested
in or
you know i sound pressed think if if um
kids in the canadian
you know english language school system
had nothing but the 60 mini stories in
french and every year they only did the
mini stories at least at the end of it
all they would understand the mini
stories you would think after five six
eight years right now i'm not sure they
would understand the many stories unless
they've been in the french immersion so
actually they're achieving very very
little in their french class despite all
kinds of instruction and subjunctive and
the tenses and things like that which
they try to kind of hang on to in order
to pass their test and then quickly
forget
so i think part of the failure in our
school system
is this emphasis on producing the
language and producing it correctly in
fact the vast majority of
english-speaking people kids in canada
have no need to speak french they have
no one to speak french with so it's an
unrealistic expectation
maybe the same is true in japan the vast
majority of japanese people have no one
to speak english to they have no real
need to speak english except for that
one time when maybe they'll travel to
europe or to you know somewhere where
where they'll need english to
communicate
but then it's too late because they've
spent all that time
you know
trying to learn how to speak and they
still can't speak again if the emphasis
had been on comprehension if at least
they have a very high level of
comprehension the speaking will come
i'm absolutely convinced but without
that solid base in comprehension
the speaking
you know they might
kind of
achieve an ability to say a few things
for the test or to produce a few things
for the test but after that it's gone
because they don't understand
fundamentally don't understand the
language so i think a big part of
failure
is this emphasis on speaking and
producing the language which is
unrealistic because realistically to
speak well you have to speak a lot a
majority of people who are learning a
language in an environment where they
don't have the opportunity to speak a
lot they're not going to end up speaking
well so it's far more useful in my
opinion to emphasize
comprehension
and let them graduate from
very simple repetitive material to
movies things of interest to them where
all the time the emphasis on
comprehension not comprehension that we
test people on just comprehension
because they're
listening to things initially that are
repetitious but then eventually things
that are of interest to them that will
reduce the degree of failure because
learners won't be measuring themselves
against something that is an unrealistic
expectation the ability to speak the
language well
they will be measuring themselves the
way i do with my arabic and persian you
know am i still doing it am i enjoying
it is it
does it correspond to what i am
interested in doing and as long as all
of those things are true even if i can't
speak well
i'm meeting my
objectives so i'm not
failing in the language but if the
expectation is that after six months i
should speak the language and then i
can't then i feel as if i have failed so
i think
where i'm coming from on this is that we
need to change the objectives
of language instruction and put a far
greater emphasis on comprehension which
means more listening and reading
letting people enjoy whatever they're
able to do in the language
far less testing far less you know
marking people down
and on that basis i think
people will feel better about their
language learning and as a result they
will learn better and will have less
failure in language learning i look
forward to your comments
thank you for listening bye for now